One of the most surprising but powerful explanations
for why we may, as adults, be in trouble mentally
is that we were, in our earliest years, denied
the opportunity to be fully ourselves, that
is, we were not allowed to be wilful and difficult,
we could not be as demanding, aggressive,
intolerant, and unrestrictedly selfish as
we needed to be. Because our caregivers were
preoccupied or fragile, we had to be preternaturally
attuned to their demands, sensing that we
had to comply in order to be loved and tolerated;
we had to be false before we had the chance
to feel properly alive. And as a result, many
years later, without quite understanding the
process, we risk feeling unanchored, inwardly
dead and somehow not entirely present. This
psychological theory of the True and the False
Self is the work of one of the twentieth century’s
greatest thinkers, the English psychoanalyst
and child psychiatrist Donald Winnicott. In
a series of papers written in the 1960s and
based on close observations of his adult and
infant patients, Winnicott advanced the view
that healthy development invariably requires
us to experience the immense, life-sustaining
luxury of a period when we do not have to
bother with the feelings and opinions of those
who are tasked with looking after us. We can
be wholly and, without guilt, our True Selves,
because those around us have – for a time
– adapted themselves entirely to our needs
and desires, however inconvenient and arduous
these might be. The true self of the infant,
in Winnicott’s formulation, is by nature
asocial and amoral. It isn’t interested
in the feelings of others, it isn’t socialised.
It screams when it needs to – even if it
is the middle of the night or on a crowded
train. It may be aggressive, biting and – in
the eyes of a stickler for manners or a lover
of hygiene – shocking and a bit disgusting.
It wants to express itself where and how it
wants. It can be sweet of course but on its
own terms, not in order to charm or bargain
for love. If a person is to have any sense
of feeling real as an adult, then it has to
have enjoyed the immense emotional privilege
of being able to be true in this way, to disturb
people when it wants, to kick when it is angry,
to scream when it is tired, to bite when it
is feeling aggressive. The True Self of the
child must be granted the imaginative opportunity
to destroy the parent when it is in a rage
– and then witness the parent surviving
and enduring, which lends the child a vital
and immensely reassuring sense that it is
not in fact omnipotent, and that the world
won’t collapse simply because it sometimes
wishes or fears it could. When things go well,
gradually and willingly, the child develops
a False Self, a capacity to behave according
to the demands of external reality. This is
what enables a child to submit to the rigours
of school and, as it develops into an adult,
of working life as well. When we have been
given the chance to be our true selves we
do not, at every occasion, need to rebel and
insist on our needs. We can follow the rules
because we have, for a time, been able to
ignore them entirely. In other words, Winnicott
was not a thorough enemy of a False Self;
he understood its role well enough, he simply
insisted that it belonged to health only when
it had been preceded by a thorough earlier
experience of an untrammelled True Self. Unfortunately,
many of us have not enjoyed such an ideal
start. Perhaps mother was depressed, or father
was often in a rage, maybe there was an older
or younger sibling who was in a crisis and
required all the attention. The result is
that we will have learnt to comply far too
early; we will have become obedient at the
expense of our ability to feel authentically
ourselves. In relationships, we may now be
polite and geared to the needs of our partners,
but not for that matter able properly to love.
At work, we may be dutiful but uncreative
and unoriginal. In such circumstances, and
this is its genius, psychotherapy offers us
a second chance. In the hands of a good therapist,
we are allowed to regress before the time
when we started to be False, back to the moment
when we so desperately needed to be true.
In the therapist’s office, safely contained
by their maturity and care, we can learn – once
more – to be real; we can be intemperate,
difficult, unconcerned with anyone but ourselves,
selfish, unimpressive, aggressive and shocking.
And the therapist will take it – and thereby
help us to experience a new sense of aliveness
which should have been there from the start.
The demand to be False, which never goes away,
becomes more bearable because we are regularly
being allowed, in the privacy of the therapist’s
room, once a week or so, to be True. Winnicott
was famously calm and generous towards his
patients when they were attempting to refind
their True Selves in this way. One of them
smashed a favourite vase of his, another stole
his money, a third shouted insults at him
session after session. But Winnicott was unruffled,
knowing that this was part of a journey back
towards health, away from the deadly fakeness
afflicting these patients in the rest of their
lives. We can be grateful to Winnicott for
reminding us that contentment and a feeling
of reality have to pass through stages of
almost limitless delinquent selfishness. There
is simply no other way. We have to be True
before we can be usefully a bit fake – and
if we have never been allowed, then our sickness
and depression is there to remind us that
we need to take a step back, and therapy is
there to allow us to do so.
Please do comment, like and subscribe
and take a look at our shop for more from The School Of Life.